welcome back to CBS morning's a
political newcomer made history in the
governor's race in Maryland his name is
Wes Moore he's a Democrat he scored a
decisive win over Republican Dan Cox his
victory speech was about maintaining
hope in the face of cynicism he
campaigned on issues like creating equal
opportunity and ending child poverty now
Westmore will become Maryland's first
black governor and just the third black
Governor to be elected in U.S history
wow Wes Moore joins us now good morning
to you and congratulations to you
Governor to be really good to see you
Wes Moore so so we were watching that
night great to see you no we're we're
very excited that you're here Wes so we
were watching that night I want you to
take us in the moment where were you how
did you get the news that you were going
to be the next governor of Maryland and
what did that feel like to you
it was remarkable
um and I remember we were we are in uh
in in in the war room where we had all
these cameras and and the teams around
crunching numbers and uh the polls close
at eight and a little out to the polls
close we were watching some of these
other results coming in and then my
campaign manager uh uh raised his finger
and uh and said hold on and he said we
just got the word we just won and the
room just erupted and the thing that was
really exciting was uh was uh was once
the number started coming in was how we
won uh that we were running in urban
areas rural areas Suburban areas we just
won across the state Democrats
Independents and we took a huge swath of
Republicans and so it was exciting that
the state spoke with a unified voice
that we were tired of being at each
other's throats we were talking about
caring more about who came up with the
idea then is it a good idea and we were
excited that this was going to be
Maryland's moment to be bold and to go
fast but we were going to do it together
so it was a great talk about being bold
though was this is your first public
office this is your first public office
this seems aiming very high and you want
this job wide
well I want this job because we know
that in order for us to really deal with
the challenges that frankly I've been
working on for my entire life you know I
tell people I've been a public servant
for much of my life I led soldiers in
combat with the 82nd Airborne Division I
started a successful small business
helping first generation students go to
and through college and I led one of the
largest poverty fighting organizations
in America but I know that if we aren't
dealing with the systems that continue
to allow people to fall between the
cracks we'll just find ourselves
repeatedly cleaning up the debris that
comes from broken systems and so I've
been a public servant for much of my
life I just haven't been a politician so
I know the approach that I plan on
taking to these problems of working
collaboratively working across sectors
and working across across political
parties to actually accomplish big
things that's exactly the approach that
I plan on taking as Maryland's next
governor well Governor uh no one elects
a resume but you've got quite a resume
uh Johns Hopkins University uh Rhodes
scholar to Oxford 82nd Airborne a
captain a paratrooper Combat Action in
Afghanistan uh what do you think it was
about your well actually no let me go
into one of the issues that you just
mentioned uh crime is on people's minds
these days uh at the very least the
perception of crime not only in Maryland
but across the country is really really
high right now how are you going to
tackle it
I think we have to move with a level of
urgency and and you know I actually came
off the campaign Trail uh earlier this
year because I spoke at the vigil of a
69 year old grandmother who was a member
of my church in East Baltimore and was
working as a custodian in the church and
she was killed in the church bathroom a
69 year old grandmother so this is real
and we are seeing this in in our
communities across the state uh but the
thing is as we need to have partnership
from the state of Maryland where a third
of all people who are who are actually
committing the violent crimes are in
violation of parole and probation so we
know who they are but we continue to
allow violent offenders off on the
streets that's something the state can
work on we have to address the fact that
we've got these illegal guns that
continue flooding into our communities
and so that means working with Federal
Partners to ensure that we're getting
and keeping these illegal guns out of
our neighborhoods but it's also about
ensuring that our children actually have
a pathway you know I first felt
handcuffs on my wrists when I was 11
years old
and I think back to myself now that if
someone would have told that 11 year old
kid that one day you're going to be the
governor of this state or a governor of
of the state of Maryland I wouldn't have
believed it we've got to make sure that
our children can actually believe in a
hope and in a promise that they might
not see in front of them right now and
that means knowing that we're not going
to arrest or militarize our way out of
these challenges
well Wes you're making a lot of people
Believers and please tell your lovely
wife on her Instagram it says proud wife
of Marilyn gubernatorial candidate she
has to change that she has to change
that Wes Moore congratulations to you
and your family I know this won't be our
last conversation and we'll be right
back